bonjour à toutes et à tous ici arcoroc
j'espère que vous allez bien on se
retrouve sur une petite vidéo concernant
spider man far from home c'est un petit
peu mon retour je vais vous dire ce que
j'ai pensé du film et ses terrasses que
ça peut amener pour avengers 4 ça a été
une vidéo très child très chill pardon
et voilà c'est de l'impro je vais
vraiment me laisser aller comme je peux
le faire pour certains films déjà ce far
from room
j'avoue je n'en attendais pas énormément
voilà on est sur une suite directe
enfin quasiment en direct de quelques
mois je pense après avengers 4 donc va
essayer de faire un énorme film après
avengers 4 c'est quand même assez
compliqué j'avoue donc j'avoue je suis
allé en mode je n'attends pas grand
chose on va voir ce qu'ils vont proposer
et au final je suis agréablement surpris
c'est je pense comme ça qu'il faut aller
voir un film parce que si on s'y attend
trop à chaque fois c'est toujours le
même truc on est déçu et las du coup
j'ai vraiment plutôt bien aimé le film
en vrai j'avoue qu'en revanche j'avais
quand même de grosses attentes
concernant la scène post générique car
voilà on est sur le dernier film de la
phase iii celui qui va donc un petit peu
ouvrir par rapport à la phase 4
et j'avoue j'en attendais du lourd
j'attendais beaucoup de choses
concernant la phase
la scène post générique et je suis
plutôt pas mécontent et surtout que
j'avais un petit mail plutôt bien hype
est un acte us tu passes par là et du
coup voilà quoi donc je suis plutôt
satisfait en premier lieu j'avoue que la
chose qui m'a frappé que j'ai trouvé ça
très cool c'est mentionné le fait qu' il
a aidé beaucoup de gens des enfants etc
sont appelés des éclipsé etc
c'est à dire que ceux qui ont disparu
n'ont pas vécu
le claquement de doigts ils ont été
absents pendant cinq ans alors que ceux
qui sont restés ont vieilli de cinq ans
et je crois que cette problématique
était très intéressante c'est plutôt
marrant du conte se retrouvent dans des
classes où du coup il ya des gens qui
ont 21 ans et d'autres saisons donc
c'était plutôt pas mal c'est cool
d'amener cette problématique car du coup
on est vraiment dans du concret etc
on est vraiment dans le côté un peu
réelle même si bien évidemment avengers
tout ça c est super héros c'est irréel
mais ça amène un petit côté vraiment
intéressant mti un petit détail qui fait
du bien
alors évidemment le coup de tony stark
c'est très bien fait c'est très bien
amené c'est que tony stark voilà il est
mort et on le voit partout quand même
c'est c'est tellement un phénomène se
iron man tony stark
quand on le voit partout les gens ont du
mal à faire leur deuil tout le monde
s'inquiète la problématique du qui sera
le prochain iron man et ça franchement
c'était vraiment pas mal je trouve
a contrario du coup captain et natacha
ne sont pas si souligné que ça donc ça
prouve encore une fois que tony était
vraiment le père des avengers qui
avaient énormément de fans de iron man
et c'était vraiment le héros clé
l'avenger clé le père des avengers est
bon sens que c'était fort 1d x j'étais
pas bien gt gt j'étais un peu triste
quoi du coup
pour iron man car c'est comme si on
avait perdu quelqu'un de proche au final
c'est même dans dans la vraie vie on se
sentait pas bien et du coup j'ai pas
comment le dire mais du coup si
m'intrigue c'est que ça veut dire que
les gens dans
l'univers du mca ont conscience que tony
est vraiment mort mais que captain
aurait peut-être fait une sorte de
voyage dans le temps après le coup de
natacha natacha était pas si populaire
que ça c'était pas vraiment le héros
mise en lumière avec des super pouvoirs
et c'est donc dans l'univers du mc lui
c'est limite un peu par rapport aussi au
réel
c'est que les gens au final voilà elle
est partie mais bon elle était pas hyper
populaire comme capitaine au final
captain je pense que c'est un peu un
miroir par rapport à la réalité avec
nous vraiment nous car captain on sait
qu'il n'est pas vraiment mort
il a juste accepté il a voulu profiter
il a retourné en passer aujourd'hui il
est trop vieux ils pu le faire donc
c'était très intéressant surtout que le
capitaine était vraiment très populaire
quand même quoi donc si les six noms
seraient amenées vraiment ce côté aussi
de deuil mais on sait qu'il est pas mort
etc
du coup voilà c'est juste une manière de
clôturer que on sait qu'il est encore
vivant et du coup ça nous fait pas tant
mal que ça par rapport à tomic qui s'est
vraiment sacrifie qui est vraiment mort
et ça j'ai vraiment aimé cette intrigue
7ce comment ils ont besoin proposer ça
vraiment alors du coup il ya intrigue
mystérieux espagne domain
effectivement les lunettes alors du coup
vraiment c'est spider man celui qui va
prendre la place de tony et ça fait sens
et c'est vraiment très appréciable
pendant tout le film surtout la scène où
il est en train de concevoir son propre
costume
c'était vraiment je trouve ça génial
j'étais comme happy en mode
[ __ ]
ça y est il prend le rôle et tout ça me
rappelle tony enfin c'est fait exprès
mais c'était vraiment très très bien
amené et même le coût des lunettes du
coup part concernant mystérieux alors
déjà le côté multi vert s'est amené pour
la blague je pense qu'un jour ça
arrivera à battre le truc c'est qu'il y
aura déjà d'autres dimensions comme
notamment avec dr strange déjà et à la
dimension noir à voir la dimension
cauchemar avec doctor strange 2 mais je
pense qu'un jour ça arrivera en quelque
sorte le multivers notamment avec
avengers 4 qui amène ddd nouvelle
timeline en quelque sorte bon et du coup
pour la blague c'est très très
intéressant c'est marrant parce que du
coup tout le monde s'attendait à
vraiment des trucs
ouf avec le multivers et c'est au final
pas du tout car oui quand un bug du coup
c'était bel et bien une sorte de
manipulateur un virtuose du cinéma en
quelque sorte
j'ai vraiment bien aimé le méchant est
le personnage je savais qu'il était
avant de voir le film mais j'avais quand
même une part de doute car on est
toujours dans le mc u etc
on ne peut jamais vraiment savoir du
coup c'était très bien amené même moi
qui savais déjà ce qui allait se passer
c'était très bien amené et puis a
vraiment des des scènes qui était qui et
où ce genre la scène où il envoie genre
spider man vraiment dans un délire
psychédélique avec tony qui sort de sa
tombe et ses terrains dans son armure
j'ai trouvé ça très osées j'étais en
mode web [ __ ] ils prennent des risques
ils sont chauds là de faire ça quand
même
mais c'était un bon risque à prendre
c'était très bien amené et franchement
non non c'est mystérieux était vraiment
très bon personnage même moi à la fin je
sais même plus des fois si on était
vraiment dans le réel ou encore dans le
rêve à moitié en quelque sorte dans le
cinéma
donc non franchement gros gros point
fort mystérieux j'ai vraiment bien aimé
le personnage
alors évidemment ils ont fait la même
intrigue un peu qu'avec les skrulls met
en mode inversé c'est à dire qu'ils nous
ont pas arrêté nous rabâcher que
mystérieux était quelqu'un de gentil de
bon alors c'était tout inverse comme
avec l'escroc l'on nous dit que
c'étaient les méchants etc voilà marvel
on commence à vous connaître
les surprises etc vous aimez bien en
faire
alors j'avais peur un peu de m'ennuyer
cetera notamment par rapport à la
romance parce que du coup c'était
l'arrivée aussi de mj et de tout ce qui
s'en suit avec etc
et au final j'ai trouvé ça plutôt très
bien bien amener j'aime bien le
personnage d' angie et je trouve que
c'est vraiment
léger en fait ça j'ai c'est agréable
c'est agréable à voir et que ça se passe
et c'était pas trop lourd s'était pas
trop dans la romance et c'est avec
vraiment le problème aussi du coût du
lycéen à moitié ou qui veut vivre du
coup son histoire d'amour est ou non non
c'était c'était de kunst éclipse tout ce
que j'ai à dire la suivante était clean
bon on va quand même allez un petit peu
dans le vif du sujet parce que je me
doute que c'est ça qui vous intéressent
de ouf
même moi aussi alors déjà le petit caméo
avec jonah jameson le premier mal le
chef de la presse on va dire dans le
premier spider man c'était cool de le
voir franchement c'était marrant c'était
bien année surtout pour dire que spider
man est encore un criminel enfin bref
voila quoi et ça amène vraiment aussi
des problèmes de société notamment du
coup bas la révélation de l'identité de
spider man et dire qu'il a tué
mystérieux a du coup ce qui ce qui est
le cas du coup en quelque sorte c'est
sait vraiment où fait c'est vrai que du
coup ça souligne vraiment que les gens
peuvent croire n'importe quoi et ça
dénonce vraiment ça et c'est bien que
marvel et toujours des messages dans ses
films et où j'ai trouvé ça vraiment très
sympa parce que c'est vrai on des gens
croit facilement plein de choses alors
que ce n'est pas forcément vrai et du
coup j'avoue que la révélation de son
identité on voit qu'ils marchent encore
une fois dans les traces de iron man met
du coup dans le sens inverse pas lui qui
s'est amené en disant c'est moi spider
man c'est ça a été dévoilée et là du
coup ça va le booster de ouf parce que
là maintenant ok là il va être un héros
il a plus le choix
son identité est dévoilé il a vraiment
plus le choix donc là ça va le booster
en tant que héros notamment après ce qui
s'est passé et tout avec nous furie même
si voilà on va en parler après mais je
sais pas trop ce que ça va mener pour le
suit mais ça va amener vraiment du
grabuge il va subir un bullshit énorme
et ça se trouve le prochain film ce sera
ça va dénoncer le cyber harcèlement le
cyberharcèlement à voir ce que ça donne
mais l'intrigué prend franchement très
intéressante et je me demande ce qu'ils
vont faire pour la suite du coup par
rapport à ça bon enfin terminons sur
cette fameuse scène post-générique j'en
attendais
beaucoup et franchement je suis plutôt
pas déçu nick fury dans l'espace voilà
ces lignes ils furent et dans l'espace
du coup il ya toujours talos talos est
toujours vivant il ya toujours les
scroll skrull qui travaillent du coup
avec le shield du coup qui va être un
peu une sorte d'armé mais dans l'espace
en quelque sorte
et j'avoue je ne sais pas trop ce que ça
va donner
enfin georges est pas vraiment théorie
pour le moment etc
mais l'intrigué ouf déjà nick fury dans
l'espace c'est quelque chose ni furie
fait rien par plaisir et c'est cynique
furet dans l'espace c'est qu'il ya
vraiment une grosse raison et ça a l'air
de faire un moment qu'il est dans
l'espace voilà d'après ce qui nous était
montré avec le coût des chaussures qui
se fait chier c'est la caméra s'arrête
pile poil aussi quand ils veulent nous
montrer ce qu'ils veulent et où ils se
dirigent ce qu'ils sont en train de
regarder c'est ce et je ne sais pas si
c'est le prochain méchant mais il ya
quand même certainement un gros rapport
il ya vraiment un truc énorme
et là on commence vraiment à rentrer
dans le cosmique et dans l'espace c'est
ça qui est ou ce qu'il ya forcément pour
moi aussi un rapport à captain marvel
s'ils allaient skrull 6 à nick fury dans
l'espace ck captain marvel ya un rapport
avec captain marvel captain marvel c'est
vraiment l'ami de nick fury cetera et si
nick fury est allé dans l'espace par
rapport c'est pour captain marvel je
veux dire c'est ça le truc quoi il ya un
truc à captain marvel et notamment les
scroll l'escroc lui suivent captain
marvel et sita l'osce a accepté de se
changer en nick fury tout le film c'est
qu'il ya un rapport avec captain marvel
c'est obligé du coup on pourrait avoir
un rapprochement avec spider man et
captain marvel par exemple luc les films
traitent
on peut des fins genre il ya tous les
éléments captain marvel dans dans spider
man far from bôme donc c'est vraiment
très intrigant je pense que c'est le
nouveau méchant très certainement c'est
ses limites obvious mais je pense aussi
très certainement qui doit y avoir un
gros rapport avec les cris captain
marvel son seul but c'est vraiment lié
fin genre calme et le conflit entre
skrull écrit on sait que ça fait 25
environ calé sur ce conflit
si les scroll sont toujours là je pense
aux côtés de nick fury et de captain
marvel c'est qu'il doit y avoir vraiment
un rapport avec les cris malheureusement
je ne connais pas trop histoire de
captain marvel
surtout qu'un élu plusieurs des captain
marvel en tant que personnage dans les
comics et même par rapport aux cris mais
je pense vraiment qu'il ya un rapport
avec les cris et s'ils veulent pas nous
montrer ce qu'ils regardaient ça c'est
vraiment coupé pile poil au moment où il
voulait nous montrer ce qu'ils
regardaient c'est que c'est vraiment un
truc lourd pour la phase 4 parce que je
rappelle qu'on est vraiment sur le
dernier film de la phase iii pour la
phase 4 ce spider man from home a amené
pas mal de choses qu'on
qui était plutôt bio ce qu'on pensait
déjà le genre la place de tony et cetera
une scène post-générique assez grosse et
tout ça va amener là on rentre quand
même dans la phase 4 ça va être ouvert
et je suis très curieux de voir ce que
ça va donner à voir vraiment on va
reparler toute façon je pense mais à
voir vraiment ce que ça va donner mais
je suis vraiment
très très très high donc voilà écouter
j'avais même pas vu qui a émis ce clip
put un mystique et su fait en tout cas
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu
cette petite vidéo le plan un petit peu
changé mais face et c'est temporaire
écoutez je vous fais un gros bisou
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à liker et
c'est à me suivre sur twitter on se
retrouve très prochainement pour une
autre vidéo il ya strangers in xillia
zelda
bref c'était dargaud rock et que le
liner soit avec vous
[Musique]